Have you ever seen a bag
and wondered what was in it?
[ Laughter ]
If so, you're gonna love
our next segment.
It's a little game called
"What's In That Bag?"
♪♪
All right.
Let's see.
Anybody have guesses to what's
in the bag?
MAN: A cannon.
A cannon?
I see that, a little bit.
A cannon.
Could be a cannon.
Any other guesses?
Back there.
A what?
A pair of fetuses playing poker?
I mean, that would be
the perfect escalation of that
bit, but, uh...
[ Laughter ]
It is not that at all.
I'm not sure myself,
but I have a time-tested
strategy for finding out.
Let me see.
Oh! Ow!
Ah! Ah!
[ Muffled ] Knock it off!
[bleep] off, man!
[Bleep] you mother[bleep]
[ Laughter ]
What's in the bag?
Let's see.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Yeah.
It's Eric André,
everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Eric André.
The [bleep]
[ Laughter ]
Get away from me.
Ah! Ugh.
What's happening, man?
How you doing?
This how
you treat me, man?
No, man. I just --
I treat you like the beautiful
black independent queen
that you are on my show,
and you put me in a [bleep] bag?
That's just -- I don't --
I'm not good with guests.
[ Laughter ]
I didn't tell them
to ball-gag you.
Listen, man, I heard --
No, you listen!
All right.
You listen, man!
You -- what?!
People are like, "Hey,
what's up with the glasses?
Hannibal keeps toggling
back and forth."
Guess what, people?
Three years ago,
he had laser surgery,
and those glasses
are fake!
[ Laughter ]
What --
And I'm here to put
the goddamn rumors to rest!
[ Laughter ]
You're right.
He's right.
These are fake glasses,
and I have perfect eyesight.
This wasn't
the place to do it,
but...even though...
I have perfect eyesight,
I identify as somebody
that doesn't.
[ Laughter ]
I'm...
trans-eyeball.
[ Laughter ]
How you been, man?
I'm good, man.
Yeah?
Yeah, I-I got
a medical salvia card, so...
[ Laughter ]
I'm one of the first.
Yeah?
Yeah, yeah.
Anything else
we should know about?
Bikram yoga.
Bikram yoga?
The Bikram dude is a perv.
Do you guys know about this?
The Bikram dude is, like,
in trouble.
What'd the Bikram dude do?
He was [bleep] fingering
the whole class.
[ Laughter ]
Really?
Yeah.
What do you think his excuse
is gonna be?
He's like,
"Uh, it's a sweaty room,
so I just slid,
and then it just happened."
Yeah.
It was like, "Ahh..."
He was doing a stretch.
He was doing, like, a Dhalsim
"Street Fighter" stretch
across the [bleep]...
"Whoops!"
"Grrrsh!"
[ Laughter ]
People were like, "Ugh,
is this part of the class?"
I don't --
The crowd is --
I like this part
of the bit.
We were done with the bit
a long time ago.
We were done with it.
It's just kind of now.
Now I'm just, like,
I'm wearing my dad's shirt,
and I'm letting my balls
swing back and forth.
[ Laughter ]
I'm feeling good.
This is --
Your show's awesome.
It is
an awesome show, man.
This is actually
all we do the whole show.
Really?
This is cool, man.
Yeah, we're gonna
get cancelled.
Oh.
[ Laughter ]
Eric André, everybody!
[ Laughing ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Somebody in the audience
is like,
"[Bleep], man, they're stuck
in a podcast up there."
Yeah.
Take your bag with you!
Eric André!